الى شرقي اسيا حيث اقرت الحكومه اليابانيه
استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده
ووصفت خلالها الصين بانها تحدي
الاستراتيجيه غير مسبوق بامنها القومي كم
اعتبرت روسيا مصدره قلقا للامن القومي
الياباني واعلنت اليابان في اطار اكبر
مراجعه لسياستها الدفاعيه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه مضاعفه ميزانيه الدفاع
السنويه الى اكثر من 80 مليار دولار اي
اثنين في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجماليه في غضون خمس سنوات كما قرر
التوحيد قيادتها العسكريه وزياده مدى
صواريخها ما يجعل الميزانيه العسكريه
اليابانيه الثالثه في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده والصين وقد ردت بجين على الاعلان
الياباني بان سياسه الدفاعيه الجديده
لليابان تمثل خروجا عن اتفاقات البلدين
بشان العلاقات الثنائيه